hey Vsauce Michael here according to the
US Census Bureau right now in America
there are 106 people named Harry Potter
1007 named James Bond and 8 people named
Justin Bieber there just aren't enough
names to go around there are more than
300 million people in America but
150,000 last names and 5,000 first names
is all you need to name 9 out of every
10 of them when are we gonna run out of
names perhaps it's already happened to
you if it hasn't
when 10 years 20 years a hundred a
thousand when will someone with your
exact name become famous so famous in
fact that your legacy changes forever to
just being not the person people think
of when they hear your name and for that
matter
when will every reasonably memorable
pronounceable band name or brand name be
taken when will ought to just start
reusing book titles according to roe v
corp owner of all music.com
the most used band name is bliss
followed in order by mirage one Gemini
legacy paradox
in the past when fewer bands had already
been created and you couldn't just
Google up every single band overlap was
easier to get away with and one word
band names were plentiful but now after
years and years and years of band
formation well we have the who but we
also have the what the where the win the
why the how and even the does in order
to stand out to now and have your own
unique name you have to be a bit more
creative Oh
diarrhea planet or Betty's not a vitamin
which by the way is no longer true Betty
became a vitamin in 1994 what about
Twitter handles or email addresses have
we already reached peak username we
already find ourselves often having to
use abbreviations initials numbers or
just choosing something completely
different
will our children or our children's
children live in a world where the only
remaining Gmail addresses are just
random strings of alphanumeric
characters are we approaching a name
crisis and if so should we even call it
a name crisis lest we use up yet another
precious name maybe you already share
your name with someone famous but if you
don't how long will it be until you
probably will I mean new famous people
are popping up all the time faster now
than ever before because of the internet
and they are gobbling up top Google
search billing maybe it won't happen
until long after you've been dead but
shouldn't the reservoir of names not
taken by notable people eventually run
out computer scientist Samuel R bhisma
naproxen
how many famous people there are alive
today and I think his calculation will
be helpful you see he points out that if
we allow famous to simply mean being
notable enough to have your own
Wikipedia page well because there are
700,000 living people with Wikipedia
pages right now that means one out of
every 10,000 people on earth today are
famous assuming at the least that that
proportion remains constant
since 255 people are born every minute
that means every hour a future famous
person is born their name destined to
become primarily associated with them
not everyone else who shares their name
all of those people will be relegated to
disambiguation or the post no meal not
the famous one luckily if you do the
math you'll find that even at a rate of
one future famous person born every hour
it would still take dozens of millennia
for most of us to expect a future famous
person with our exact name to emerge
plus names change new ones become
popular others obsolesce but for fun
let's not focus on names we popularly
use and instead look at how many
possible names there can be the Social
Security Administration allows up to 36
letters for a complete name now
including spaces 27 letters filling 36
spots with repetition allowed means 3
sec's de Cillian possible combinations
that's more than Earth has atoms so
let's refine our limits
how many pronounceable names are
possible for that I say we look at what
Randall Munroe
the author of the fantastic what if did
when asked about naming stars if you
want to give every single star in the
observable universe a unique but
pronounceable English name how long
would the names have to be his
approximation is really fascinating if
we define a pronounceable word as a word
that contains consonant vowel pairs we
can roughly figure that there are about
a hundred and five different such pair
possibilities 105 that's not too much
different from 99 so funny enough there
are about the same number of consonant
vowel pairs possible as there are two
digit numbers which means we could give
every star in the observable universe a
saleable
unique name with just 24 letters the
same number of digits it would take to
just number all of them so the bottom
line is we may each have to give up
uniquely owning a word or name that's
common today but the potential number of
names that can be made is really Hardy
in fact before we run out of those our
species will likely evolve to
communicate in a completely different
way also names aren't just labels a name
on a screen a username a handle a screen
name doesn't always act exactly like its
owner user names can travel more quickly
and more widely than flesh-and-blood
people and do things that their
puppeteers wouldn't normally do away
from the keyboard
it's called the online disinhibition
effect if you can't see the people
you're interacting with and they can't
see you you're all just online hiding
behind different names than usual why
hold back
I mean clearly such a system can't be
serious business on the internet no one
knows you're a dog why be nice or tell
the truth the subreddit karma Court
investigates and uncovers people who may
think that the less face-to-face nature
of the Internet makes lies easier to get
away with like this person who posted an
image suggesting that they've been
single for a year but had users found
out posted three months earlier a
picture of my girlfriend's cat these
behaviors aren't just what humans do
when they can be anonymous or can hide
behind different names these behaviors
can also be caused by the names
themselves studies have found that the
username you use can impact how you
behave your own pre-existing stereotypes
and expectations of certain words shapes
colors can be confirmed by your behavior
in the same way that studies have found
NFL and NHL players play more
aggressively when wearing black uniforms
studies have also found that the more
sexualized an avatar is you make someone
use the more conscious they will be of
their own body image and the more an
avatar resembles you the more correlated
you watching it exercise is with you
being more likely to exercise more
it's called the Proteus effect the
features of a cyberspace version of
yourself a username and avatar can
actually change you the meat space IRL
you usernames and avatars then aren't
just handles attached to us
psychologically we often interact with
them as if they're friends distinct
beings we created they help us out but
they also can influence us I guess on
Daris to do things we wouldn't normally
do because they offer us protection
entertainment some make us feel safe
professional funny dangerous attractive
we want cool ones the cool ones make us
look cool as we go about our daily lives
and vie for attention we are more and
more frequently doing so with another
name and exclusively through that name
only so it becomes quite interesting
that we're not going to run out of them
anytime soon in fact they might run out
of us first and may in many ways run us
and as always thanks for watching
[Music]